that's my hilarious Leonardo DiCaprio
impression
okay guys I'm in a rush right now it's
Danielle's birthday if you guys have
seen the channel Danielle it's her
birthday and she doesn't know that I'm
really running late I really have to
talk about the revenant honestly that
little opening bit just really tired me
out watching this movie like I'm more of
the kind of critic that comes from a
place of feelings I can be analytical
and I could like observe things
logically but at the end of the day I go
by a film based off my feelings when
this movie was done I remember saying I
liked it a lot and in some ways I loved
it I cannot stop thinking about this
film I love this movie that's why I sort
of like to wait to do a review because
sometimes it takes my feelings to like
really figure out where I'm coming from
here this movie is fantastic it's
definitely one of my top three favorite
films of the year there's so much good
things to talk about first thing I was
really drawn to above the performances
was actually the fact that this film was
done with natural lighting
gorgeous gorgeous [ __ ] beautiful
beyond it looking beautiful it adds so
much to the story because this film it's
a simple revenge tale I don't want to
give the revenge tale away because I
noticed that even though it's in one of
the trailers a lot of people still don't
know the actual plot it's a revenge sale
and it's also like on this journey of
revenge it's man versus nature the whole
time I forgot what time this
specifically takes place in but the
focus of the atmosphere and you know how
this director loves to do his long shots
like he did Birdman the long takes and
he does long takes again here it's like
perfectly choreographed with wonderful
actors so the authenticity of the time
and what it's like to be a traveler a
soldier or wanderer during this time
period how [ __ ] terrifying it was it
was [ __ ] scary I was thinking like
man this was I grew up in America and
this was this is just a few hundred
years ago [ __ ] it was really tough to
survive we are all [ __ ] spoiled
children so this film it's it's [ __ ]
violent it's brutal like there's it's
not like violence like the whole time
but there's a good amount of scenes
where it's just [ __ ] brutal and it's
not done in
like an entertaining way although it is
entertaining but it's not done in like
some flashy way because the violence
it's it's like when there's chaos going
on in this and though in the little
battlefields it feels [ __ ] real and
it's disturbing and brutal and sometimes
it's like the shots are so wonderfully
planned that you'll be like oh [ __ ]
there's like a guy in the corner who's
[ __ ] dying right there you'll just be
looking at the whole scope of everything
Wow the the wide framing of everything
was made it that much better to capture
the authenticity of this time it's like
you're in that world and it's weird
because I saw this with Veronica and she
actually said this and I agree
this film takes place over quite some
time not a long time but it's definitely
at least a few weeks at the same time it
feels like it's real time because you're
so pulled in to this organic world like
I really am curious to find out where
they shot this film because it looks
like we're in the past the performances
in this film are wonderful DiCaprio is
one of my all-time favorite actors after
the departed he has been one of my
favorite actors ever since and oh man
kids shut up I'm talking about the
revenant right now day after Christmas
and they still won't shut the [ __ ] up
DiCaprio is powerful he's shown us
through a bunch of films his wide range
of emotions this one you really see the
physical commitment that is going on I
wanted to make sure to avoid as much you
know article isn't behind the scenes of
this movie as possible as the trailer
sold me so much that I wanted as much to
be a surprise and as fresh as possible
there are sequences in this film where
I'm like they clearly filmed this in the
snow and DiCaprio is like going through
the water at time I want to point he's
naked in the snow it's like dude this
guy just really [ __ ] committed he he
is primarily suffering during this film
when you watch it's like The Passion of
the Christ
if it was nature just trying to take
down Jesus you know he is just going on
this mission and the worst things just
keep happening to him that's one of my
minor issue
with the pho it's really not something
that I was like really hung up on but
DiCaprio when I look back at was someone
like he survived way too much
there are things where I'm like he would
have gotten an infection he would have
died just from that his wounds would
have been cut open like this
there's several dip picky details I can
go through but it's it's still an
entertaining [ __ ] film and you're so
engrossed that you kind of don't really
like register that because after
something sort of unrealistic happens
they back it up with more realistic
scenarios
so the Caprio physical performance in
this film is [ __ ] magical it's like
every moment that he's struggling it
really feels like he's struggling I love
that he's this like huge [ __ ]
celebrity but he is really going out of
his way to go I'm not just a famous dude
like I'm a real actor you feel a whole
character you don't feel like you're
watching DiCaprio you feel a whole
character yet he doesn't have much
dialogue you could probably count the
few lines the guy actually has and some
of them that are not even in English
so yes DiCaprio Oh out of all the
performances I've seen this year I'm
really hoping that you get the Oscar Tom
Hardy I want him to get an Oscar too
Tom Hardy is fantastic the thing that
mesmerizes me the most about this guy is
I've seen him in so many [ __ ] films
but every single time I see him I just
see the character I don't see Tom Hardy
and he does it again like he's the
villain in this film weirdly like you
get an understanding of why he is the
way he is and even the choices he makes
that you strongly disagree with there's
still a party that's like I kind of get
where he's coming from though his
performance of this like traumatized
dude who is like just on the road all
the time you could you could feel so
much behind him every single line of
dialogue because he has significantly
more dialogue than DiCaprio and he
carries that dialogue extremely well
he's got a wonderful monologue here and
there the whole embodiment of him you
don't see Tom Hardy you see this like
nasty gritty [ __ ] his voice
sounded so authentic I'm like I know
that guy's British but damn is that
voice sound real I love
- because he's a famous [ __ ] guy but
he's not out to be like good-looking
celebrity he yeah I got this ball being
a twin he has like disgusting ears got a
big beard like he is not the most
attractive looking dude in this film and
he uses the makeup to his advantage so
this film is just so immersive like even
with my complaints at the same time of
the moment of those complaints I'm like
it's still a pretty powerful moment like
in the trailer you see that scene with
the bear it's actually a really
important scene and that seemed with the
bear it's like yeah I can tell the bear
CGI but it's still like mesmerizing to
see how I'm like how did they do that to
DiCaprio that Hadley just throw him
around in [ __ ] it's just one shot and
he's clearly not CGI so I don't know if
there's like motion capture involved in
some way it was still a really powerful
intense scene like one thing I really
give this some credit for is its
maturity - its violence its protest but
it's real it's not done in a flashy way
it's done in a way where the violence is
really disturbing however it supports
the authenticity of these times like the
way the action was captured in this kind
of reminded me of children of men and
that's really not a complaint like it is
it's it's way more violent than children
of men like do that just watch the first
15 minutes and it'll be this movie it
starts off in the first 15 minutes like
wing [ __ ] around this time the
dialogue of this film is great there's
not a lot of dialogue and when there is
it's just not expositional whatsoever
this is a revenge tale and it treats its
audience so smart that there's not a
single line where DiCaprio's like a mini
get revenge or anything like that yet
you're like this guy's on a [ __ ]
revenge mission right now it's treats
its audience smart it lets you just
study the behavior of its characters in
its world the music is fantastic in this
film the sound effects are great in this
movie the sound effects make everything
feel more I really wish sound design
guts a lot more credit because the sound
is so [ __ ] important to making a film
work and it is flawlessly done I hope
this film gets an Oscar - for its sound
design and
least the nomination for Best Picture
and a nomination for Best Director
please
anyway guys yeah that's my review for
the revenant if you're new the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
that film is just fantastic that
fantastic you know like it makes me
wonder if that's how DiCaprio really
sounds in bed camera cut not done that's
incoming hmm can't go a video though sex
joke sorry yes